get back to that breaking news the fire
clark county firefighter is battling a
situation this morning a two alarm fire
at a business complex this one started
really early about 1 30 in the morning
this is sunset and mcleod as you heard
nate talking about this is right across
from sunset park bianca holman joining
us live with details bianca good morning
good morning so this all took place in a
business park you can see several
businesses surrounding where the fire
happened and it is now out there's only
about two units still here on scene but
it was a very different picture earlier
this morning
before this roof collapsed you can
it was a very intense fire we were able
to speak with the witness who says it
was very chaotic when
firefighters arrived
it was a lot of a lot of chaos a lot of
firefighters they were they were really
going at it trying to contain this thing
a lot of yelling on the radio and it was
chaotic
now we're told about 70 firefighters
responded to this fire looking on google
maps it looks as if it was a nail
boutique and then also another maybe
non-profit business next door and you
can tell that inside of this business
park there's a courtyard area so it was
contained to just this part of the
business and again there's a two units
still on scene they're going to of
course continue to investigate this and
let us know the cause of the fire but
some good news here there was no
injuries reported no one was inside the
business and then no firefighters were
harmed we're going to send it back to
you guys in the studio